good morning c'est sûrement l'une des
premières phrases qu'apprendront les
jeunes et en courtois chez les Petits
Bilingues une école originale où la
priorité est d'apprendre l'anglais en
s'amusant mais surtout de l'aimer
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est un plus
et un atout pour les enfants de parler
très tôt l'anglais comprendre l'anglais
et c'est une façon de s'ouvrir notre
culture qui est différente de la culture
française pour qu'il puisse acquérir un
meilleur niveau d'anglais que que nous
moins de difficulté à apprendre et puis
quand on commence au plus le plus je le
plus jeune possible on a un
apprentissage beaucoup plus facile donc
voilà je voulais lui en faire profiter
dès l'âge d'un an les bambins peuvent
découvrir le module first step
accompagné de leurs parents et apprendre
l'anglais jusqu'à l'âge de 12 ans pour
acquérir un accent s British une à 2
heures par semaine pour 200 à 400 € par
l'enfant va intégrer en fait des
sonorités euh qui sont des sonorités
différentes de la langue française et
donc dès le plus jeune âge il va être
capable en fait de reproduire des sons
qui sont les sons spécifiques à la
langue anglaise chaque groupe de travail
est constitué de 6 à 12 enfants maximum
à hencour les activités débuteront au
centre allé Guy Boniface à partir des
vacances scolaires de
mars